from the very beginning you know that
France is that shoulder to shoulder with
you and since the very first time we met
together when you were at that time you
cannot do they get dressed yes not yet
president
um we're here and we will be here to the
very end be sure about that
thank you very much first of all to you
for your support during all this period
of time during before full-scale War
you've been with us France and your
Society always supported that thank you
so much my appreciation that we had were
a good meeting in Paris
and very very important tough decisions
which make us stronger on the
battlefield and on humanitarian
Direction because for us it's very
important that people to be strong
and thank you for all this support and
we spoke a lot about about future Jazz
Coalition and I want to thank you and
all the partners about this this about
training mission is really really very
very important I will share with you our
meetings
uh yesterday which has been very
important that for us is very important
to involve to this formula as much as
possible countries and I'm happy that
there are very positive signals
we can do it it's a simple word